i
[Música]
a
el gobierno alemán hizo pública este
martes su intención de acoger a mil 553
refugiados más que actualmente se
encuentran en grecia el anuncio fue
presentado por miembros de la coalición
del gobierno luego de que los últimos
días se desatará un fuerte debate aquí
en alemania sobre el rol que debe
cumplir el país en la acogida de
refugiados en particular luego del
incendio en el campo de moria
inicialmente el gobierno alemán había
indicado su disposición de acoger entre
100 y 150 menores no acompañados pero
esto sólo hizo que aumentara la presión
sobre el gobierno de la canciller
alemana angela merkel para que hiciera
mucho más dado el peso político y
económico que tiene alemania dentro de
la unión europea el anuncio de este
martes probablemente no satisfará a los
partidos de oposición en alemania los
verdes por ejemplo habían pedido que
alemania cogiera a muchas más personas
mientras el partido de ultraderecha
alternativa para alemania había pedido
que no se acogiera a ninguna el gobierno
alemán de cualquier manera hizo énfasis
en que además de estas contribuciones
individuo
se necesita una respuesta europea para
tratar el problema de los refugiados en
grecia
[Música]
el incendio en el campo de refugiados de
memoria de la isla griega de lesbos ha
vuelto a recordar la unión europea que
aunque no siempre salgan las noticias la
crisis de refugiados no ha desaparecido
el incendio en este campo de refugiados
ha vuelto a pelar las conciencias de los
líderes europeos que aún no han aprobado
la reforma de la política de asilo y de
acogida en la unión europea de hecho
lleva años bloqueada y hace cinco años
acabo de dinamitar sé cuando más de un
millón de refugiados entraron en europa
por el momento ya hay diez países que se
han comprometido a la acogida de 400
menores no acompañados entre ellos
francia alemania o bélgica pero la unión
europea sabe que esto tan sólo es un
parche por ello la comisión europea ha
avanzado que la propuesta sobre la
reforma de la política de asilo en la
unión europea será el próximo 23 de
septiembre con la esperanza de que todos
los países europeos se impliquen en la
crisis de refugiados
[Música]
tras el incendio en el campo de moria en
lesbos los reflectores apuntaron los
países de la unión europea que dentro de
poco deben presentar un nuevo pacto
migratorio a iniciativa de la canciller
alemana angela merkel diez países del
bloque se comprometieron todos juntos a
acoger 400 menores no acompañados de
lesbos parís dijo que va a recibir entre
100 y 150 alemania una cifra semejante y
el portavoz del gobierno francés dijo
que este país no luz de sus
responsabilidades en materia migratoria
sin embargo las cifras no parecen decir
lo mismo el país está lejos del ejemplo
que dieron suecia y alemania durante la
crisis migratoria del 2015 y el 2016
en ese entonces parís se comprometió a
relocalizar a 20.000 demandantes de
asilo de italia y de grecia sin embargo
sólo cumplió con un cuarto de sus
compromisos este año antes del incendio
en lesbos parís dijo que iba a recibir a
400 demandantes de asilo de lesbos y a
350 menores no acompañados sin embargo
con la crisis sanitaria de por medio
sólo llegaron a francia una cincuentena
de menores
[Música]